the gyro can experience what's better
than a Thai style kickboxing on a Dutch
there's no better man the thing is like
look at Ramon Decker's Ramon Decker's
went over there and he [ __ ] everybody
up in Thailand and he was there sighs
it's the athlete but it's also how they
incorporated in you know just look
there's some great Thai fighters like
who the [ __ ] is forget how to say his
name that just doom Bay just knocked him
out big time Thai fighter he had like
200 Pro Taif i'ts he had so many and
Dumais caught him with a right and glory
caught him with a right hand the clinch
and kod him it's like everybody sty and
Dumba is more of a kickboxer it's
everybody it's it's the athlete but
everybody style has merits yeah like
there's merits to just being that
wrestler who ground in pounds and
doesn't throw many kicks
there's merits to be in that jiu-jitsu
guy that doesn't care if they get taken
down it's just like who are you though
are you are you Demian Maia on the
ground you know I mean if you're Demian
Maia on the ground there's merits to
that style you Amy and Maya his
strangled a whole lot of world-class
killers that never even got a punch off
on it lose my I got it I was it yeah
well maybe [ __ ] they [ __ ] David Myer
Knobble Eva's the guy he knocked out in
his last fight doom-doom Bates a beast
well Cedric Dumba is an interesting guy
man because he reinvented himself he was
more of like a runner not I want to say
a runner but more of a mover and he
would win on points and he would but
then he just the last few fights it was
a couple fights ago two or three fights
ago he fought I forget Alex forget out
say the [ __ ] name city ty guys have
those crazy names hi
but I want to do I'm going to do some
stuff what a glory to glory is amazing
gory does not get the respect that it
deserves now I'm a giant fan i watch all
the glory yes that's what fascinates me
about what I can do yeah because people
just think is UFC no anatomy of a
fighters for everybody
anything yeah it's all of that said your
doom babe before concentrate on that
dude he's my fave numbe poof yeah boxes
man
flatlines everybody he's gonna there it
is sit song Penang that's it
tongue-tied sit song Penang say that
real quick don't cha sing song some go
back to his a that so that guy that he
fought Tong chai tom CH I had like I
mean hundreds of heights I don't know
how many [ __ ] fights he had total it
was more than a hundred times i'ts and
then a shit-ton look 136 wins
yeah 175 [ __ ] fight I'll take 39
losses if I've won 136 times yeah he
fought a hundred and seventy five times
that is insane
so I mean he's got that Thai style we're
doomed aids more of a kick boxers done a
lot of times people say well they prefer
the Thai style because the elbows and
the clinch and the knees but doom Bay
flatlined Tim it's the athlete
it's the way they incorporate their
style competing against the other style
and there's merits to kickboxing I
prefer the Thai style because I think
there's there's a real benefit to being
really good at the clinch yeah to be and
especially when it comes to MMA real
good at the clinch the knees to the body
the elbows in the clinch and kickboxing
doesn't allow elbows or knees to the
body but we've seen world-class kick
boxers that have come on like like cro
cop yeah I had a tremendous success in
MMA going from kickboxing into MMA I
always wonder where like somebody like
Ray Sefo man would do it's my prom in
MMA like well look at mark hunting and
Mark hunts had a tremendous run and Mark
Hunt he Ray Sefo right yes he did yes
he fought Ray Sefo I mean when you go
back to mark hunt Mark Hunt really happy
when he won the k1 Grand Prix was
probably he's in his prime as an athlete
and then he fought a lot of fights and
prides by the time we got him in the UFC
I mean marks in his 40s now right that
thing is mark still where is he retiring
he just lost his last fight right who he
lose to Willis
yes yes he lost it Willis yeah I think
so I think he's retired uh I don't know
but he's probably close you know
at a long-long I said why not when I
when I was living in flood like my home
gym is hard knocks 365 that's why I
started that's Henry who's I love that
guy that's like my big brother man I
love it like a great trainer he needs a
platform to tell his life story because
it's crazy
Henry office he just got back from
Thailand he went over there he told me
he's like I just got away from the game
for a couple weeks and I came back
refreshed hmm
because you know he's Abby's like I
wouldn't want to like get caught in an
alley with Henry hoof guys a big fella -
yeah Hollis me I'm kick your damn Lee
Nia that's who she is
I didn't piss them off a couple times he
didn't kick me through the cage why I
just complaining like complaining like
egg who's manis people didn't pay me
enough and he like quit complaining like
fell back I was like yeah I was like
holding on to the K so my hoof is a bad
man man you don't want to get on his
bass he's a great Troy here's a girl he
a great guy
[Applause]